have they tried like have they tried
throwing ladies your way like
genuinely like me personally I think so
um I think that there have been several
cities look wait a minute I'm dead
serious I'm not joking I think there's
several things one time Miami Miami
yes
he's got the Dolphins colors right now
that's Dallas yes L.A there have been
times where Dallas must be throwing you
some ugly women the way you talk about
the Cowboys oh they're Cowboys
Cowboys
there's a lot of noise
I don't know what the hell you talking
about Dallas is kind of nice but I will
tell you this seriously
there have been times where is I'm like
I don't think I'm Godzilla I think I'm a
decent looking dude but I ain't that
damn good looking these women being a
little too aggressive oh there are times
that I felt like that and it was like it
was during the finals one year it was
during the playoffs another year and all
of those cities that I mentioned and all
like nah nah you know I'm saying no I'm
walking away not just that you get to
you know you're going to the front desk
finding what room I'm in why I gotta
change the name of my hotel room like I
gotta go by you know I gotta go by you
know like like what is that hey Steve
I mean it had to do something like that
but I had to like yo what the hell is
going on here there were girls knocking
on your hotel knocking on a hotel door
trying to hook up the whole bit no but
it was like but again I'm looking at
them and they look pretty damn good and
I'm like this is
I'm just looking at it I'm like
this is ridiculous it's fine as hell and
how why you chasing chasing nah
and you dressed nice now before it was
the baggy but now now before it was just
the bad guys
but the point is that that's what they
were doing and I was like this is too
much no I don't look that damn good I
ain't that I I ain't one of these
Superstar players oh hell no I smelt the
setup and when you let me tell you what
what was time what will stop me in my
tracks real quick
is when I think somebody trying to mess
with my money
police myself it ain't worth it
it ain't worth it it ain't worth it yeah
get your ass in your hotel room close
that door refrain chill out yeah
[Laughter]
life I can't go celebrate for my money
yes I can wow
that is wild that they're sending I
don't like I said I don't know I'm not
saying that I'm that's humble of you I'm
not saying I'm coming from a position of
knowledge I'm saying that I suspected it
because I'm like no I'm not one of those
dudes that you know what oh I couldn't
get a girl till I got on television I've
always been blessed we know I've always
been a blessed
but the point is is that despite being
blessed in that regard you know in terms
of women instead of women wanting to
meet me in the whole bit
I ain't never had these I never had no
women come after me the way some of
those women came after me and I I can
tell you you could call it whatever you
want but
I'm one of those dudes you don't have to
worry about on the road like yo you know
what's he doing how he acting oh hell no
no no no no no no no no no I guard
myself like like you know like like like
I'm money in the safe I'm I don't play
you know I I go out it's with my inner
circle I don't just hang out I'm gonna
you know if I'm with my girl that's
different if I'm with my family or the
people that work that's different I
don't go to strip clubs but I don't I
don't I don't go to Just Parties by
myself I don't put myself in a position
where I can potentially get exposed
somebody slides some [__] you drink or
whatever oh no no no none of that I got
people around me at all times but you
know what's [__] up is like
those girls found out about you and fell
in love with you probably from their
boyfriends watching
like their boyfriends are watching their
show and then they're in the background
doing some big talks and [__] like oh
here's a kind of nice voice and the dude
didn't even [__] see it coming yeah
that's true
there's a slight issue with what y'all
are not seeing okay but that's just as
important y'all acting like that's the
case with a dude that's on television
that's usually the case period with any
of y'all think about it
think about how you've met somebody
think about how somebody had a house or
somebody else has met your friend or
whatever the case may be you do have
people that plot you do have people that
it's like you know you could you could
have your you could have a lady and she
meet one of y'all and she's looking at
you like yeah but she with you oh it
does happen
and by the way men
are obviously worse men are obviously
worse because we see some [__] we like
you understand a lot of times
at some point in time or another in our
life we didn't care about who we were
with um so we can't do don't act like
it's TV it's anybody I I literally I
never forget years ago man it was um
this was about 20 years ago I went to a
journalism conference
and I watched himself
I watch two people who I knew were
married
go into their room together
came out of the room
went downstairs
to meet their respective spouses hey
maybe they were journalism
yeah you're even journalists journalism
it's like it doesn't matter y'all it
doesn't matter
you're a man or woman anything's
possible it doesn't matter what industry
you in it doesn't matter what's going on
and when you are a journalist slash
commentator pundit whatever you
connected to the fourth estate which is
the meat and stuff like that
see it all you see it all and I can't
even begin to tell you the things that
I've seen it make you scared to get
married makes you scared to get married
wait what kind of crazy what do you mean
have have women are you telling me there
have been like players wives have
they've tried to throw you to prep
baskets no not me yeah what I'm saying
to you is that there are players who
have been traded
because
they were with a teammate's wife
there are coaches there are coaches oh
no who have traded players because trade
players was getting with somebody they
would get wet they are they oh there are
they uh listen it happens everywhere
y'all talking to me because I do sports
but the fact of the matter is sports
Wall Street you can be in medicine you
know somebody the doctors and nurses
working at the hospital look man since
Adam and Eve just been going on stop
acting like we don't know
what you talking about yeah yeah we're
all married I never met anybody you know
yeah you know what you married that's
exactly the answer you should give
would you get married again I've never
never been married oh that's right you
have kids though yes you do yeah yeah
but would you get married once
yes really yeah I've done it all
these guys
[Laughter]
I've lived a good life
I've lived a good life you know what I'm
saying I I you know I'm I listen I'm not
proud of the fact I'm not proud of the
fact that I've never been married but I
am proud of the fact that I didn't get
married and not honor marital valves not
even come close to it right at least I
didn't do that yeah so you know I mean
there comes a point in time where you
know you get sick you know you want
somebody there to nurse you back to
health you come home you you know you
yeah that's the reason you get married
gotta have a significant other yeah
you get about 24 hours damn sure ain't
because you have this overwhelming
desire to be the most monogamous
monogamous person on the planet no you
just get to a point where it's like you
know
and it's cool
this overwhelming disaster you just wake
up one more I need to be faithful
wake up wake up I mean listen I'm proud
of any man yeah any man yeah that says
I have found the person that I want to
spend the rest of my life with and I
have zero interest in any other human
being on the planet
yeah that's not me
[Laughter]
oh but you get in there I think no no I
I I'm over all of that yeah
overall what all the monogamous stuff
I'm over or I'm over listen I've I've
been I've spent the vast majority of
Pinky Got a Boner you're talking to us
ever since I will tell you I'm 55 yeah
ever since I became a dad my life
changed oh really prior to that
just Reckless
it was crazy it was bad it was bad just
call me
you put you
know no nothing it was in Philly it was
never like that it was never it was
never like it was never like that but
you know what it was yeah it wasn't so
much what I was doing because I was
never that bad it was what I wanted to
do meaning that you know what I would be
with someone and know
there's no way that I'm this is going to
last yeah right because I'm going to
want to be with someone different when
we're running around all of that other
stuff nah you ain't doing that but what
you're doing is you're like I have no
intentions we call that terms
for once once I became a father
the scary part is is like you know you
especially when you got daughters you
like this
damn
I don't want her to run into somebody
that I was like oh you know you start
thinking about all of a sudden you know
what are you excited all of a sudden all
of a sudden you started going like you
know what the word Karma means yeah you
didn't know what it meant before then
but now you're like [__] I know what I
mean now karma was a stripper in DC yeah
you're looking at all of that you're
looking at all of it and it's like nah
you know but but it it changes and you
know it's like you know you don't feel
like you're doing anything wrong you
know you're single you're not married
you don't have any kids and you're very
very honest look I'm traveling 200 plus
days out of the year I'm not trying to
settle down but then you find somebody
special and you want to be around them
but you still sense it's not going to
last all right so then it doesn't last
and then you get with somebody else and
then that doesn't last against and you
don't care then you become a dad and all
of a sudden everything you didn't care
about now it's an overload you caring
about that all the time you like Lord
please don't do this to me don't don't
make them run into somebody like I was
yes man you can sit up there and you can
look at a whole bunch of people that's
much much worse than you ever were but
the fact of the matter is you're
thinking about you and you're thinking
about how you were and you're like [__]
yeah why did I do this why did I do this
why did I but you have daughters right
yes that's what I'm saying but they
won't know what it's like to does it
matter I don't know
I know that's what I'm trying to say I
know I know how I was I know how I
thought yeah I'm like oh [__] threesomes
a lot often no no no let me ask no no
comment triangle offense
I'm not getting into all of that that's
too personal of courses too but I heard
you would leave ESPN and just go
[Music]
he was running boxing one
I sat up there and I was like yo nope
I'm chilling out I mean listen most
people I've been around with all my life
I'm talking about my boys my you know my
you know my cousins people like that
they were far more Buckwild than I ever
was yeah but that didn't make me
innocent right and I know that okay so
when you become a dad it's like [__]
yeah yeah so this is this is the thing I
feel like when people talk to you this
is why it's exciting to talk about this
kind of stuff because when people talk
to you for the first time I'm sure
they're always going like here's my
sports take what is your opinion on it
you know what believe it or not
um I try to make it very very clear to
people that's what I do that's not who I
am that's what I'm saying you know it's
a lot more to me that's why I like I
like to joke around I like I like to
clown around a lot and I love I've
always been with because I've grown I
was young as a six got four of the
sisters 90 of my relatives are females
whatever so that's where the risk comes
from I always love I always love being
around the fellas and just shooting the
breeze yeah like being in a room filled
with testosterone and stuff you know
what I'm saying yeah I like that yeah
you know that it makes you feel free
because it happened to me often so when
people get me around it don't have to be
about women all the time but they ask me
questions I'm not running from anything
but that's the cool thing is like
because I feel like somebody is opinion
is you is going to have these same it's
not like you're just going to be opinion
about sports it's going to be a politics
it's going to be out anything
relationships and it's all these kinds
yeah because that's how it is at home
exactly I mean if you're being real
about it who goes home and just talk
about what they do for a living no you
really talk about a lot of things that
are expand beyond that and so for me
it's not something that I ever run from
and if you want to hear that no mercy
his podcast now yeah every single topic
that's right yeah you don't run from
anything yeah I love it and you know
what I'm saying so I mean it just is
what it is and I'm just having a ball